this place my god what happened to him
he didn't last very long did it
you found our cat huh
bloody hell dead cat like cabbage
welcome nice to meet you always good to
see you too
golden first name is Melissa Melissa
good morning how are you Lisa crap Lisa
nice to see you got no very happy I do I
it's my resting face Wow yes
welcome to the Vienna that's not happy
to be here well I'm to the cat food cat
got run over I see
and you gotta stuffs probably right
actually better to see you right I'm
yeah love the Attar by the way thank you
everyone wears this wow how much are the
outfits about 300 $400 $300 3 Everidge
you know they get their own I mean there
are their own dresses you know oh you
buy your own uniforms yeah stop heads we
do them for many years and it reminds
them to not gain weight Wow so who
designed the place well my husband and I
and whose idea was it to buy it for me
um my husband she said wasn't yours it
was not my ideas actually very much
against it
Wow why are you against it it was very
overwhelming I had two small children
but probably after I lost my mind the
first year I think we started to get a
hang of it and whose Austrian are you my
husband South Austrian or polish right
I'm not nearly as exotic I'm very
American right and he's the chef right
so he runs the restaurant kitchen and
you run the inn correct and whose idea
was the violins on the table mine
where'd that come from that was actually
from an estate sale down the street a
dead man's violin yes why not
I don't assert across the table with my
wife and look at dead man's violin well
bit freaky no no what would you rather
look at when you see the Vienna huh
who's hurt my wife Oh your wife yes yeah
but you have to have something to make
up that white space so what would you
suggest my wife
you're gonna put around the table that's
not a scandalous I am so [ __ ]
confused dead man's violin what about
some flowers
Wow
interesting indeed yes a flutter room
service come in
holy mackerel now what we have here is
some pulled boar yes right and then you
have a little celery root right on top
well and what's that
it's a little parsley excellent what
take one did you like you two have one
do you cause the stream three pieces
here exit thank you thank you for sure
you're welcome don't wait wait let me
put the wither the garnish on there well
yeah we'll have a little piece eat
what did you think of that by the way
celery root really don't like it the
full bore maybe just a bit more soft Wow
and what did you think of that I think
it's a nice little surprise for people
when they come in to liven up their
appetite ball was very watery
it was very water it the bread was soggy
soaking wet are you from the celery root
thank you Joe you stay please pass on my
comments to the chef I definitely will